vor gut zwei wochen habe ich dieses
video hochgeladen namens das schönste
mädchen der welt
ja ich bin verliebt in diesem video habe
ich auf einen typischen tag im leben des
schönsten mädchen der welt reagiert und
falls ihr euch jetzt fragt hey schönheit
liegt im auge des betrachters ja das ist
so allerdings gibt es eine gruppe von
menschen die bewährten wäre das schön
für mich die welt ist und sie hat hat
gewonnen
falls ihr euch fragt wer sie ist das ist
toulon du eine frau bei euch auf jeden
fall habe ich in meinem video sehr krass
von thilo geschwärmt so dass auch viele
von euch begriffen haben mensch der luca
der steht auf die schüler jetzt waren
freunde aber wir verlinken 1000 bildern
foto schotten das und das ging mir dann
irgendwann zu weit weil ich ja auch
nicht zu nahe treten wollte und dann
habe ich dieses video hochgeladen es
geht zu weit weil es mir halt zu weit
ging es allerdings auch wahnsinn war war
dass dann viele leute auch dachten ja
wir foto schotten die einfach mal wie
sie sich küssen hier beispielsweise oder
hier haben sie das auch gemacht oder
hier so ein bisschen schlechter und auch
hier so im disneyland immer kommt ihr
klar die hatten freuen
ja das war unangenehm
bilder von euch tage vor dem
schaufenster zu sehen während schüler
halt wirklich einen freund hat also ich
wollte mich jetzt keineswegs gegen die
anderen machen das war nie irgendwie
meine absicht allerdings habt ihr nicht
aufgehört und die habt weiterhin bilder
bearbeitet und ich habe mir gedacht ich
beende diese komplette serie mehr oder
weniger einfach damit in dem ich noch
mal auf die wirklich 100 schönsten
mädchen der welt reagiere in dem video
ich bin verliebt und in diesem video kam
selbstverständlich nicht nur too long
vor sondern noch 99 andere personen ich
habe dann auf die 50 hübschesten mädchen
gesichter 2009 zehnmal glaube ich der
korrekte titel reagiert weil ich 100
nicht geschafft hätte einem normalen
video und hier ist mal ganz kurzer
ausschnitt
[Musik]
ich will mir dieses video nicht anschaut
so ging es mir hat die ganze zeit
während dieses videos weil ihr müsst
euch einfach mal vorstellen hier steht
ein ganz normaler 08 15 typ dash
aussieht und schaut sich videos von den
50 hübschesten frauen der welt
könnt ihr euch vorstellen dass ich dann
auf dauer nicht mehr der einzige war der
hier stand allerdings kamen weitere
action und zu einer person die mir
wirklich besonders krass ins auge
gefallen ist hier mal ein ausschnitt wie
ich live dann die person entdeckt haben
soll falls sie nahmen falls ausspreche
den fange ich jetzt gar nicht an trotz
entsprechender gc
[Musik]
das ist kälin slevin oder irgendwie so
heißt sie wohnt in los angeles amerika
und ich habe gesagt kelly kam zu können
also nach köln auf englisch war selbst
ihr könnt alle glaube ich besser
sprachen als ich ich hab dann auch noch
dumme witze gerissen haley würde ich
gern kennenlernen
ich schäme mich manchmal echt für meinen
humor und meine videos und auch nicht
manchmal sondern eigentlich rund um die
uhr auf jeden fall habe ich dann diese
palin slevin einfach mal gegoogelt mir
wird dieses video hier wirklich
zahlreich zugesendet nachdem ich ja
schon vor einigen tagen auch thilo
reagiert habe und hier ja immer noch
nicht aufhört mich und schüler zu
photoshop danke übrigens dafür
vielleicht erkennen sie mich dann
irgendwann ja und
habe ich habe ich bilder von ihr
dann auch gefunden kehlen
es gibt wirklich hässlichere
menschen
a
und kurz nachdem
ein video online gegangen ist
wir zählen darauf instagram geschrieben
peabody energy baut ja viel alu leiter
sales also anscheinend ihr lieblingswort
diese nachricht hat sie mir auf jeden
fall am 13 mai um 21 nachts gepostet
bitte gepostet wahrscheinlich diese
nachricht angeschrieben nachts in der
nacht nachdem ein video online ging
und ich hab dann am nächsten morgen dass
sie geantwortet
youtube direct to video the one hit no
spacing unit bittet jahr freunde ihr
müsst euch waren gang runterschalten was
für das andauernde luca sagt er mag ihr
das aussehen der person weiß ganz genau
welche fanpages wieder dahinter stecken
auf jeden fall habe ich dann weiter
geschriebenen story für den convenience
sure you can eat the history channel put
your message is well post in meist doch
okay ich kann wieder absolut kein
deutsch
dabei kennt herrn bei followers zu kamen
dort die anymore haha das war ihr und
herz weil ich dachte kurzer zeit in form
übrigens dazu sie hat das mini ihre
story gepackt von da habe ich das auch
nie meine sache gepackt
allerdings hat sie dann geantwortet was
denken sie denn von ihrer reise sind zu
bis zu 20 mädchen der welt
dogru pages kindern ist ein exklusives
video bereitet airbus probe beginnt ein
geld alle podcasthörer was wir unter dem
wort verstehen
die crew
hier sind wir sind so so sind wir
dougan
das krasse war dann allerdings dass sie
wirklich mehrere minuten später noch
geschrieben hat weitere brände materie
straits teil
[Musik]
ich habe war lose an und weiß auf jeden
fall habe ich dann geantwortet ha ha no
problem ages genau der teams mehr fans
kein bier little bit neuen ja leute
wirklich gang zurückschalten
genau so schaltet man zurück mit dem
konzert wird die luft immer bild gümbel
ich habe mich auf jeden fall wieder in
meinem namen für euch entschuldigt weil
ich nicht wusste was jeder wieder für
bilder in photoshop hat und ich wollte
nicht dass sie dann irgendwie ich denke
ich habe ein freund ist das jetzt eine
masche an mich ran zu kommen oder
irgendwie so auf jeden fall weiterhin
geschrieben text interesting to know how
and thank you you tube öffnen die nieder
haircut ahk bei ihr geschrieben
ich brauche haarschnitt ich weiß beim
friseur
auf jeden fall hat die kellen daraufhin
geantwortet auch der wall also leute die
luft wie lucio die ganze zeit hier so
sind wir keinen auch gut so
so sind wir mitteilen
dich
ich bin da damit ich bin kehlen und da
ist die luke schumann redete kam im
september die settings lese lukas und
love it you are actually of chaos online
leser luca tonis video laser look at
what you think pad olfen leitet josef
fans durch ssl war das jetzt eine
einladung
ich bin so gewünscht auf jeden fall
hatte ich mir danach noch geantwortet hh
ok am very happy day i did not have the
series all things d
der tag endete lederbezug fasern times
leute das kann ich nicht oft genug sagen
ich möchte auch nicht dass jetzt wieder
tausende screenshots gemacht werden von
mir und ihr und das bearbeitet wird und
kommentare und nachrichten bitte gang
zurück sagt sack wir sind so mitteilen
so und ich will nicht dass wieder so
wird also wir bleiben ja zusammen lupe
und blöd aber dass die dann aber ich
glaube die ist eh schon bis hinweg
wieder weil ich habe weiterhin
geschrieben also nicht sehr rosig pretty
mama fans immediately first out hh sorry
bremst extra du mein bester action to be
right now but love auf lagarde camps und
youtube die zeit rast no der snow es
ripley within the next month we're going
to europe und dann ja schon sehr die
nachricht gesehen angeles beyoncé
sie hat mir jetzt seit anderthalb wochen
nicht mehr geantwortet
palin muss weg aber meine lieben freunde
das ist jetzt wieder zeitlich gesehen
komplett an anfang springen wir jetzt
und zwar direkt nach meinem teller video
habe ich auch toll eine nachricht
geschrieben und sie nicht darauf
geantwortet hatte bis jetzt meine
nachricht natürlich war es so hey today
sagte thür video showing typical day in
your life in mein community mit crazy
und photoshop pictures of a tcs wurde
toiletten oder das wars in may and enjoy
your best friend sorry for the
inconvenience unexpected luca das habe
ich hier am 26 april geschickt also vor
drei wochen
sie hat lange zeit überhaupt nicht
geantwortet ich hab da noch ein zweites
video dazu gemacht wo ich ja gesagt habe
junge leute kittner bitte ein bisschen
mit den ganzen tollen bildern mein video
es geht zu weit hab ich euch jetzt
beginnt schon erzählt und dann habe ich
ja auch noch auf diese 100 leute da
reagiert die 100 schönsten gesichter und
lustigerweise genau in dem moment wo
kellen mir geschrieben hat hat sie mir
auch geantwortet du dort nämlich
geschrieben hey you very nice to meet
you
und da dachte ich mir halt so viele
palin als ich nicht bei einer mülltonne
auf jeden fall habe ich die leute auch
geantwortet habe ihr geschrieben einem
fein hahaha you choose what to make sure
they do not get me my fans can go little
bit to the times when it comes to the
pin starflash.de jahr leute wie bereits
tausend mal gesagt place zwei gänge
zurück wir sind so viel los hier auch
und vielleicht kriegt man die die hat
einen freund dass das kriegen wir nicht
hin auf jeden fall habe ich dann
weiterhin geschrieben ein
aussagekräftiges in einer video follow
up das situation and opportunity to stop
tax in waiting pictures of a hard day's
in klammern also damit meine ich halt
das video nämlich hat gesagt habe es
geht zu weit leute schild mache ich wenn
ich das irgendwie abgelöst weil sie auch
im freund hat etc
dann hab ich noch geschrieben i hope you
house of finance difficult times and
sorry mhh und sie hat die nachricht
gelegt und das auch gesehen und ja auch
noch nicht wieder geantwortet also es
gab es einen moment
während das mein video online gehen und
danach da dachte ich so ja geil
vielleicht schreibt es mir dann hat es
mir aber nicht geschrieben
red eine mail geschrieben und ich war so
auf dem mount everest und jetzt bin ich
wieder bin ich so im erdkern wieder mit
mehr selbstbewusstsein was mädels angeht
das war auf jeden fall mein heutiges
video meine liebe freunde ich habe euch
ja damals schon in der enns ramsauer
gesagt nicht allerdings nur ein paar
minuten drin hatte weil ich mir dachte
nee will ich jetzt doch nicht so
öffentlich machen habe ich euch ja schon
gesagt dass die lobby unter anderem
geantwortet hat das kennen wir auch
einfach von sich aus geschrieben hat
einmal halb so viele leute von euch luca
journey to the very nico und ich so
jetzt bitteschön schreibt mir eure
meinung in die kommentare soll ich da
noch mal nachhaken oder nicht palin
desserts on diamant ich bin eher so dass
hier viel los an rubin und ich bin dann
auch eher so dass hier so eine flasche
wisse die nicht mal volles dies leer
vor allem wenn das mit thilo so weiter
geht dann wird ihr freund so angucken er
wird sich aber gefallen heute meine
lieben freunde dann einen daumen hoch
unter dem video da schreibt mir bereits
gesagt und eure meinung zu der ganzen
situation whatever in die kommentare und
jetzt befinden es auch schon im auto
hier oben ist es zwei die wände werden
hier draufklicken dem einen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren verpasst nicht mehr
diesen wundervollen content und wenn ihr
schon aber dann klickt kann auf die
glocke denn dann bekommt er eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen und hier ist ein video
verlinkt dass du immer auf einem zwei
kanal online gegangen ist da hab ich
nämlich auf dem promi fleisch beitrag
über mich reagiert
[Musik]